welcome to this video playing Rob on
okay one game one loss so that I get on
the scoreboard with this guy aha that's
early birdie there should be 83 more
usually they only do it with Knight f3
and should be for first okay um can I go
f5 okay at least this is going to be an
original position nadia 3 however though
and I probably have to take and and you
yeah i was thinking knight c6 but this
is definitely risky night could be
misplaced but okay it's at least
interesting night have six next now it's
probably not really good what I'm doing
here so
I even d5 might be on plane that didn't
happen you just plays it enough the
somewhat simple fashion which does not
mean bad yeah what's Bishop one if was
really strong okay so light squares okay
anyway I didn't really see Angie six as
a good alternative so what now I cannot
go to five unfortunately night before he
has prevented hmm
coming over to h5 and I will not want
attack but I really have to connect Luke
somehow i can't go bishop g6 also i'd
say what what a bad idea the Queen comes
here Bishop g6 is really a pest you can
probably find some funny ways to let by
Queen to trap my queen or really awful
a queen e ad was a really really
terrible move
wow that's really unplayable this
position it's really bad not just a
little bit just blah yeah the worst
thing is it's the easiest game ever for
white I'm very simple play maybe this is
not the best possible way to play for
him at least here I get some stuff
traded I think that could have been
worse but still no pic leg
yeah maybe maybe this is kind of
playable
I don't see anything particularly grade
for white so cantique here nah 95 maybe
just 95 if he takes takes you still
cannot take on e6 because of the made on
g2 and they have possibly look f6 who
gave aid 95 okay very ambitious move but
maybe good job hmm route 8 even as h4 in
the mix this is a really really really
tough to face move hmm the saying some
d7
h4 yeah I know maybe I can play this so
I mean it's losing but what can you do
we should age seven wins everything wins
no time morning didn't see that now at
least the game continues for a moment
Bishop age 7 would have killed
immediately huh if I getting e5 I can
really continue and play this position
that that wasn't really the best way for
him I've got one pawn and we have three
I know it doesn't have that many options
with this rooks he's still better of
course but we should be seven I would
have just resigned check now see 45 is
the idea here to try to open up see
final tigo will be five so we took care
of that
20 seconds so at least I can can make a
couple of moves cm and at the end he has
to take care and/or this pawn him be
sure to f 7j group d aids is the only
move that here i found it played them
pretty badly technically but Jack didn't
didn't really help much check black
forfeits aren't I for real time now he
has screwed up to completely to a draw
yeah anyway I was too too bad too slow
yeah and he could have won just with
Bishop h7 and so on the whole opening
was just am just a disaster yeah I think
I shouldn't simply shouldn't play in
this kind of way and just then it's just
unsold Yemen unsound and this is really
bad i mean i can never ever ever go to
h5 as bishop g6 is coming so yeah
yeah I'm kind of getting back into the
game and I g5 is just bad you 295 yeah I
didn't I didn't see the move and it's
it's ready I have no reply it's just
this really loses did something like
this is ok ok I just losers i have no
way out yeah here he just he didn't play
porsche boxster blew the sister just
makes this kind of games frustrating
sometimes because this is the easiest
whenever check check enter that's it so
instead he got into this end game Bishop
h7 also was winning ok anyway then you
went up to the end game where it's not
even that clear maybe I don't know this
is me I don't know check probably can
defend this better I wonder how no it's
still bad I don't think that the
computers evaluation after 0.4 this is
right I think it's better than this it's
more than that because white has ideas
and turns really difficult for black to
do anything so well here I felt like I'm
out of the woods and the computer agrees
it's equal check but they only had 10
seconds check just three seconds I
possible to do and now it's of course
just to draw position wise but now I
mean I definitely deserve to lose this
game the opening was so terrible it was
an entirely 30 playable position ok
thanks for watching